as a quick warning there'll be spoilers
in this video because i'll be talking
about every devoted logic aspect in the
movie
the first scene is a flashback where
lebron is playing a basketball match and
before it starts he plays on the gameboy
for literally
15 seconds as a result he gets roasted
by his coach and then later they lose
the match
the movie then blames a loss on lebron
for not being focused enough because he
was playing
a video game like what are you on about
writers
someone playing on a game boy for a few
seconds doesn't contribute to not being
focused for the next few
hours then the next scene doubles down
and states that playing video games is
too distracting for lebron's career and
needs to be
discarded you could be a once
once-in-a-generation
talent if you focus on the game of
basketball
and not these distractions i guess
playing video games no matter how much
means that you can't be successful
i get you need to put in the work but
that doesn't mean you can't have fun
along the way
after that annoyance we go to present
day and meet the main son of lebron
named dom
unlike lebron he enjoys video games and
he also develops and creates his own
games
during the scene dom and his brother are
just casually messing around and that's
immediately interrupted by lebron
barging in
and complaining that they aren't taking
basketball seriously and that it should
be
work everything in between these four
lines is work
why is the movie immediately portraying
lebron to be an unlikable [ __ ] who is
a stuck-up father that forces his kids
to take basketball very seriously
honestly this makes me see lebron as a
partial villain in the movie instead of
the stupid ai that becomes the
antagonist later on
then lebron pulls out dom's nintendo's
switch-like device and acts like it's
contraband
how dare you bring that here also at the
end of the scene lebron practically
looks into the camera and says this
can't be great without putting in work
thank you writers for bashing this
message into my unintelligent smooth
brain because i clearly didn't
understand it the other three times you
said it in the last
five minutes it's worked that's cause
your brother been putting in that work
you can't be great without putting in
work
for the next scene i guess the writers
realized they made lebron very unlikable
and were too lazy to rewrite the last
scene
so instead they tried to make it up by
lebron's wife roasting him for being a
terrible father
to which lebron does a complete 180 and
has a heartwarming moment with dom
and is suddenly very accepting of him
playing video games and making them
also if lebron is anti-distractions aka
video games
then why did he even give dumb a god
gaming setup to begin with
seems pretty contradictory but oh well
and of course the scene ends with a
totally rad dab
poggers then we meet algae rhythm
and i'm just going to call him algorithm
i don't feel like wasting extra
syllables on that stupid name
so his deal is that warner bros made
algorithm to come up with most of the
entertainment that they
output in this movie his pitch is one or
three thousand
which essentially takes any ip with some
warner bros
and it inserts any actor they partner
with into it aka
lebron james yeah that's a pretty
atrocious idea and i guess warner bros
self-roast themselves by the fact that
the warner execs in the movie think it's
a great idea
also it doesn't make sense to me that
the algorithm is so obsessed with
partnering with lebron james
the variables he considers as successful
are being a family man
entrepreneur and a social media star not
you know being a movie star and actually
having the ability to act given that
they're dealing with shows and movies
just a thought with that logic why not
go with dwayne the rock johnson
a social media star family man and a
blockbuster superstar
but eh whatever i guess lebron james has
bigger star power than anyone in
hollywood apparently
then to add insult to injury dom in a
warner bros pitch meeting by the way
reveals that he wants to go to e3 camp
instead of basketball camp
to which lebron gets really upset at
this point in the movie it's really
confusing as
if lebron actually supports dom given
that the last scene he seemed okay with
video games taking up a lot of his time
and that he was actually very successful
in that field
but the second it compromises basketball
it's apparently
unacceptable also while this is all
going down
algorithm lowers them down into the
server room via the elevator
and sucks them into the server so am i
just supposed to excuse dom turning into
an idiot all of a sudden
when an ominous server room opens the
door for you and says your full name
you should be walking the other
direction instead of walking towards a
big weird ball of energy
but hey we wouldn't have a movie if this
plot point wasn't forced into existence
it would be nice if the writers actually
cared about not compromising character
intelligence to move the plot forward
but
that's just me i guess
[Music]
see nothing to be afraid of the
computer's black
i can see that was that supposed to be
funny
so to summarize really quick algorithm
holds dom hostage and challenges lebron
to a basketball match and if he wins he
will let them go
so now lebron has to assemble a
basketball team and algorithm eats him
over to the tune world
and what follows is a barrage of
pointless advertisements in an attempt
to sell the audience with some amount of
false
joy after finally entering toon world
lebron runs into bugs bunny and within a
few seconds of meeting him
the writers couldn't help themselves but
make a big chunks joke
congratulations writers then for the
next few minutes they just do completely
random [ __ ] that doesn't move the plot
forward at all
it just comes across as absolute chaos
and i was just confused as to what the
hell was happening and why it was
happening
then once bugs bunnies adhd dies down a
bit they finally discuss things and move
the story forward
here lebron actually does something
pretty smart and says that he wants
people like superman king kong
and the iron giant on his basketball
team but that's just immediately
undercut by bugs bunny being like nah
we're reassembling the looney tune squad
which surprisingly doesn't get a lot of
resistance from lebron
as it should have you and your son's
life are literally on the line and you
aren't going to insist to get superman
and other overpowered people on your
team
also while on the spaceship there's a
really dumb and insulting moment in
which bug's money goes into his own
backstory
of being left by everyone on tunes world
because of algorithm offering crossovers
but that's just immediately interrupted
by a cringy ad for harry potter
it's the only place where i can be me
where i belong is that harry potter
world
and that's the third time they shoved
harry potter in our faces
like finally the movie is giving us a
sort of interesting backstory just to
immediately shell out for a cheap
reference to harry potter for
quote unquote entertainment then the
next 10 minutes is just going to
different warner bros ip defining the
symbol everyone from looney tunes
that a lot of these references are for
very mature and adult franchises like
the matrix
game of thrones casablanca and mad max
to name a few
so is this movie trying to target a kid
audience or an
older audience with these scenes like
why not incorporate the vast amount of
kid-friendly ip that warner bose has
given that they owned cartoon network as
one big example
but instead we get a lot of poorly
integrated crossovers like the granny
from looney tunes wearing a black latex
suit dressing up as trinity in the
matrix
i really wish i could unsee that one so
then their team is assembled and more
chaotic and random [ __ ] happens during
training
while that is going on lebron's wife has
gotten worried and is now looking for
him
and for some reason warner bros allows
anyone to enter into their server room
i know algorithm unlocked the door but
there are no security guards around to
stop this
also find it funny that the main
elevator is able to access their server
room
you think it would be significantly
harder to get in there similar to a
vault or something but
whatever later on algorithm manipulates
dom into playing against his dad and the
game is now
starting for the game it is being live
streamed and if you are watching it you
get sucked into your phone and show up
in the server verse
that's obviously a bit goofy but it's
very forgivable since it's a wacky
concept
so this means that lebron's family is
both playing the game
and now watching it in the crowd before
the game starts
algorithm now states that if lebron
loses then everyone will be stuck in the
server verse
i don't really know how that benefits
the server by just having a bunch of
random people in it
because the whole reason of keeping
lebron there was for his influence
but hey let's just raise the stakes for
reasons
i guess the only reason is so that
algorithm can have a permanent audience
but that's not really explained
then lebron tries to warn dom that
everyone's creative algorithm wins
but dom is like nah algorithm is just
misunderstood and completely glosses
over and ignores the fact that algorithm
kidnapped thousands of people
he is a kid and they can easily be
manipulated but
given that he met algorithm like an hour
ago and trusts him more than his own
father
is pretty wild then it's not like he's a
stupid kid or anything given that he's a
full-blown game designer at age 12.
right after that moment leron walks over
to his wife asking what he should do
you gotta win this game and get
our son back yeah like no [ __ ]
obviously he needs to win thank you for
the reminder writers
then the game starts and there's nothing
really devoid of logic about the
sequence given that the game rules are
video game roles and really anything can
happen
although there is one thing about this
sequence that becomes distracting which
is the sheer amount of easter eggs in
the backgrounds
as an example there's a moment where
algorithm is talking to dom
but the night king is sitting right
behind them with whites
it's so distracting to the point of
where i'm not really paying attention to
their dialogue and just thinking about
how stupid the niking looks here
one of the most menacing villains in
history has evolved into a silly little
easter egg
it feels like the writers are trying to
band-aid fix their flawed movie with
excessive easter eggs
but if anything it feels like it
detracts from the movie and puts a lot
of focus on references
instead of the story halfway through the
game
lebron figures out that he's taking the
game too seriously
and he needs to let the looney tunes be
themselves to play better
what follows is them catching up through
different wacky ways like having a rap
battle with the other team
which was unique to say the least i'm
not
exactly sure what we just witnessed here
then once the score is tied up lebron
basically pauses the game to have a
heart-to-heart moment with his son
in which he finally accepts him for who
he is
especially after the movie has been
bombarding us with that message
be yourself so now dom and lebron have
rekindled their relationship
and they decide to play on the same team
this leads to algorithm taking over and
it's revealed that he can actually
control the game
which is demonstrated through him
reversing one of their successful
shots but if that's the case then
why does an algorithm just undo their
entire score or rewind their score back
to where they had nothing
it's not like it resets the time or
anything if they set up algorithm to
have complete control over the game and
he doesn't fully utilize his power then
why would the writers even introduce
that mechanic in the first place
algorithm is clearly powerful to begin
with and he has been cheating
but apparently he needs to be even
stronger despite him not actually using
his power effectively
it just creates a false sense of
hopelessness for the heroes
oh no he rewinded our score by two
points what will we ever do
then obviously the heroes win an
outsmart algorithm by using a glitch to
disable his power
by winning everyone is then released and
goes home
honestly i'm kind of surprised that
algorithm stuck to his word and let
everyone go given that he was cheating
all game
you'd think he'd be like psych you guys
are actually stuck here
because there's nothing really forcing
him to let everyone go but don't think
about that
that would be a bad ending then speaking
of the ending
lebron is back on earth and runs into
bug's bunny and the movie doesn't
explain
as to how he got out of the serververse
along with all the other looney tune
characters
so i guess that just means that any
warner bros ip can just get out of
serververse now if they want
interesting so yeah that's space jam a
new legacy
i know this is technically a kids movie
but that shouldn't excuse these
massively budgeted movies for having bad
writing
but in essence that's the whole point of
this video series making fun of bad
writing and pointing it out and
analyzing it
i hope you enjoyed the video and there
will be other devoted logic videos in
the end screen